what up citizens of the reject Nation we
are here for part four of our reaction
to the cutcenes for Spider-Man on the
puss five Andrew how are you I'm good
but Greg I need to know why aren't we
playing dude what's going on play it's a
great question man well you've been
playing I was doing the math without the
amount of editing that I've been having
to do for the channel I probably won't
get around and sitting down and play
this game proper till closer till after
Thanksgiving actually I have the game
and I I'm like I probably won't be able
to sit down play but you were saying
there's some stuff here we chose the one
of the longer Cuts scene ones still some
stuff that's apparently missing even
though I cut out some stuff here just to
keep some of the flow going there's
still some other things that you you
caught that we didn't see at all yeah
there's some stuff with Uncle Davis
which I'm very shocked that uh has not
been included some uh side missions like
some photo op stuff with Robbie
Robertson the stuff I noticed but I have
not caught up to where we are talked
with some other people who have been
watching with us and they're like no
we're still C catching the main story
though yeah yeah and I'm still loving it
right now and I I can't wait to actually
have like the holiday to just enjoy for
sure final predictions though who is
Venom my god dude I'm telling you it's
Harry like here's what I'm think it's
going to happen all right yeah from
where we're at I think Harry is going to
go through some Darkness while Peter is
you know having the symbiot suit and
then by the time Harry gets it back he's
going to become that that honestly does
sound good to me and I actually probably
do agree with you that's probably what's
going to happen and I'm going to be
wrong it's the build and the stature
that keeps getting me like that even
that statue that I showed on part part
three just doesn't look like Harry's
building I know Venom is always way
bigger than even when it's Eddie it's
like always a little bit bigger in
general but sure ah I don't know but
you're probably going to be right and
I'm probably going to eat crow and it's
not going to be Craven but you will not
eat crow we'll see what happens all
right man just let's enjoy it just chill
out chill out let's watch it now flip
that like button thank you you all have
been watching let's
[Music]
go believe this is right around the time
where we reacted to in that trailer and
still in control of his green Alter
Ego Dr
Connors Dr Connors you here how long has
that been going off that is a great
question
you know for as muscular as Peter is
small ass it's not it's not America's
ass he got to be doing some deadlifts
and you know what I mean heard his
wife left with their son after the first
lizard Fiasco she didn't want to give
him a second chance she doesn't believe
in second chances like Norman con loves
his
Secrets hey you got some secrets of your
own now too PE we remember in that
trailer he busted out of the ba it
looked like a basement or something
reptile terrariums for Connor's initial
limb regeneration tests I never did find
out how he lost his arm he cut it off in
a saw trap triggered the security
cameras about 30 minutes ago what did he
see I thought that was him in 127 Hours
he was trying to test his
blood come on Dr Connors fight it you're
watching old
footage
again they really hone in more on the
horror elements
here horror mutation side Conor and his
family through hell oh there it is hear
that Freeman's going to
pay I think Yuri lothal is killing it
man absolutely killing he studied
addiction before they uh started filming
so he get into character with the black
suit oh for me I I just practice
addiction before filming
that's what keeps that's what keeps me
energetic all the exactly how Craven
likes
it Connor's
blood cover the door oh here we go here
it is oh great to catch up to this
yeah
wow no idea no idea that's right we
reacted to the gameplay we know
I might have seen that a million times
after that after we reacted to it
triangulating position Target located at
Harlem Fish Market I don't know give was
crap but I like it this way because I
could just take in the story and and I
can experience the gameplay for myself
even though I know gameplay is part of
the story I understand I understand I'm
excited to review the story
[Music]
after a glad we're getting getting to
spend time with these two on their own
yeah okay all I see
it here we
go Lee is still out
there the city needs me it's Spider-Man
right now it's cool when he does sign
language he does that Spider-Man right
now I'm glad that she knows
though that was a great
line but would you crave miles if he
wasn't Spider-Man that's the real
question guys what's going
on the
market yeah yeah I'll be there Wonder
are we sounds like on the other line I'm
raging out miles I'll text
you
it's
beautiful the mural I
mean no you're beautiful you're
beautiful you're what how is it you are
beautiful looks empty but I better check
it
out guess I'll have company after
all go go go taser two keep it
tight they're using drones to track the
lizard maybe I can use them too oh hack
that a passive defense
system oh W yep good to know going to
keep my
distance I was just going to say they've
really upped the the gameplay difficulty
in terms of these Hunters they're
actually tough to fight okay my su's par
ing now God bless Unix okay rebooting
the altimeter
and it's
alive how do I look like a robot drone
man oh that's really cool and a robot
drone that's tracking the lizard awesome
that was fast it's like when they have
ai companion but it's not an AI this
thing handles like a
tank no this is going to be bad keep it
together don't
stress I'll meet you on the other
side this really feels like a horror
movie right
now
W It's like got an
alien oh oh look at all them dead
fish oh spooky guess what's behind love
the way they mess with the shadow there
cuz you think it could be a
creature dude where the hell were you no
idea but I've seen some things same man
let's just find this lizard dude cool
yeah drone doesn't have a lock on him
though wow this is actually spooky
nerving what are the
odds it's just oh it sheded it damn
doesn't that mean he's getting
bigger hungrier
too oh it's his first time seeing him
like this yeah meeting him in the
shadows too hey man new threads the
building's swarming with Hunters any
sign of Connors uh yeah yke track I love
how cold he is he's just like new
threats and I'm not going to bring up at
all what the hell you just saw
mean but the date is incomplete think I
can help with
that is that
blood hey wait a sec try dropping it in
here I'm
scanner handy dude so nice to have three
Geniuses on hand that's how I feel when
John's with us okay I think I got a lock
gy wait be chill thank
you that wasn't me just always boosting
my self-confidence I don't even have a
stomach
so let's
go
it's like they're chasing a dinosaur
take him
alive
woo can't lose Connor Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the drones I got the jet
skis oh I'm so excited for this Mission
I borrow
this this is really really exciting keep
it tight man impecable camera don't
worry they think I'm like the way they
seemlessly transition yeah the tracking
and it's
incredible oh man Mobius it's like
Alejandra in yantu is uh the
director damn take him out y having a
yach party without
[Laughter]
me
damn the intensity behind this the East
River it's like Godzilla man Godzilla
the Jaws version Spider-Man is fighting
on right
now this is so
terrifying between Sam man now lizard
there is this Kaiju element help the T
booat I've got the metal murder
bird I love that line I warned you about
going after Connor now this is on you
yeah you can uh slide on the water like
that now that's excellent that all
you've
got almost done here civilians are all
safe that's incredible this gunship
won't quit I'm right behind you we'll
take it down together no time I love the
anger in his
voice yeah Yuri's killing
it
time to go boom boys no no no no
Spider-Man is G
defenses got carried away got carried
away it's anger clouded it's
judgment oh yeah those are the same Nets
that they caught Tombstone with all
right over there two one with the T move
move
ah wow that is
scary wow that is scary terrifying how
much bigger he's
gotten I love how obscure they're
keeping him yeah it almost has feels
like Jaws in a
way he's right behind you I know I know
it's like the Alfred Hitchcock
approach
faster so
scary Dodge miles I want to be lizard
food
wow wow yeah I love the scales on
him
hold
on out I love how this guy's just been
casually fishing and not hearing any of
this going on he's in the middle of
doing something important and you're
zoned in you're zoned
in I can't all these people in danger
remember that's it well that's like such
an important element making sure you
protect people in this game why it feels
so lived in wo
wow three
[Applause]
[Music]
Aly yeah that was
great good you
on
damn love he just throws him like this
Punk made me save you now he got
away he got away from
us it's good
Pete I saved the
tracker let's go man before he gets too
far
no he's mine you sure this is personal
he got big teeth so do
[Music]
I oh what he's not normally like that
right no does
he he's never like that do the Venom
teeth thing right now not that I know
and that's where we got cut off on the
our trailer damn I don't even remember
that from the trailer G Play trailer
yeah I remember the first
bit oh The Amazing Spider-Man one you're
alive I haven't heard from you in a
while I'm close to finding Dr con how
you liking my suit man soon as I stick
in with the antidote the suit's coming
right back to you maybe you are right
okay let me know when you find him dude
it's like when sharing a girlfriend yeah
now it's been corrupted it's never the
same anymore it's why he becomes Venom
oh wow now you can see him struggling
without it
oh but it is interesting how like you
did didn't feel the anger and at least
we didn't see it from Harry like I think
a lot of it was like pushed down but I
mean look his life's every his love has
been destroyed understand human beings
Andrew wonder if this is the same sample
Connor's used for his original formula I
was wondering that too this is our
particle accelerator at the
foundation Conor's used it to break down
some
mineral
uh was that
me is it responding negative is
gravitating towards it power's
out okay what are we working with
here that's not it oh nope oh those
little flashes of his eyes oh that's
great I didn't notice until
Emoji don't get carried away hey Doc
that is ready for your an
physical
damn this it's like what Batman fights
bit
[Music]
that whoa you need a symbiot to how how
did Peter fight him before
yeah used his brains
Greg
nice oh
no damn I love the design
wow but where's his lab
coat holy this this really comes oh
no oh my God
yeah wonder if Conor suspected that
might
work oh no you
don't that's
great yes yes I feel like that's a
reference to I mean you could say
Jurassic world or even Godzilla in 1998
the trailer when it Stomps on the T-Rex
or Jurassic
Park really not in the mood for the
rampaging lizard in New York City thing
right now there's been so much
destruction New York is getting just so
jacked
up oh would it be a Spider-Man gam me
for not riding a monster throughout the
city
he going to St
oh where's Craven is he just
observing I got this officers you're not
helping I find these chases so thrilling
oh yeah for
sure here it
comes you can't get through his skin R
it
damn it the needle
stuck woohoo just love as time passes he
gets angrier and angrier love how the
camera just can swoop into a completely
different track shot oh my
god oh crap dude he's carrying a car up
a
building he going to do at the top or
he's towing a car up a
[Music]
building
oh my
God that sound weakness really is a
hindrance
[Music]
huh
oh I must get my prey I the ultimate
Hunter aren't I after all
that c just shows up at the last second
beautiful
creature oh
no wow what a predicament I got you it's
crazy cuz Spider-Man's actually trying
to save him that oh
no oh get his tail it's okay they
regrow just drop it
[Applause]
in
no oh so his arm must been dis located
and it like fixed
it Shadow shot he's expanding he's
getting Huger regeneration is so cool
and so gross I love how he can have
admiration in a moment like
this man this is a really extensive
fight wo
oh time for your
medicine taste taste of your own
medicine
doctor oh no more jackal and
hide then he just drowns to
death you should definitely go find
him
hurry he's
naked crav just going to shoot him I am
the best
hunter
where did you get that Harry Osborne he
said you designed
it come with me if you want to live he
knows it's a threat oh yeah you could
see how terrified he was like where did
you get that in like his eyes too for
sure got to get rid of it
yeah is he want going to want to get rid
of
it it's just as I thought
uh-oh oh oh it crashed land he found it
ah okay I thought he just thought they
were going a different origin it's over
here whoa whoa whoa back off he like
created for a closer look all it's okay
it's okay is this how he lost his
arm oh oh
interesting
fascinating why would he lose his arm
doing
this cut it
off Sho it off yep yep yep
[Music]
yep
damn to free himself
from
oh wow it's Kryptonite it's a fragment
of a meteorite that landed outside the
city years
ago it's where we found
[Music]
that this makes so much more sense why
Norman had that now an alien we call it
a
symbiote it it the cellular level with
it host uh in our case Harry
Osborne he gave it to
you no exactly exactly yeah I was hurt
and and it CH you well the whole time I
was trying to get to him even when it
was on Harry yeah which means it's more
dangerous than I could have imagined
it's we need to call we need to destroy
it it's keeping Harry alive destroy us
us uh-oh
uh-oh it's almost having like the Auto
Octavius effect and yeah know that's I
think it's a great reflection after what
happened in part one makes me a better
Spiderman
uh-oh thought it was going to hurt
him okay now I'm leaning a lot more
towards your version of
Venom but we shall
see eyes on the target pursuing
I'm going to go to
bed I'm going to sleep
peacefully that's the story I was
telling you about is the relationship
going to deteriorate mg can't wait to
read it
wow way to be dismissive you're still in
the suit I thought Connor was going to
help you get it off what about Harry
sorry can we do this tomorrow just so
beat from Lizard
ring it's an interesting image though in
bed it's okay Peter we protect
you it's terrifying it's a mind of its
own and it feels alien by all accounts
you know I feel like you would have
suspected that somewhere
uhoh uh Peter you're not going to get to
bed tonight oh damn they're going to
destroy May
home oh he's on it oh man is he going to
fight them
asleep like in Spectacular Spider-Man
that many guns did you just spoil
something for me I'm sorry did it happen
you haven't gone there I only watched an
episode or no that's your fault had
months this is why we're reactor cut
scenes
can't go out the windows downstairs is
my shot dude MJ's capability of taking
out Hunters is
incredible just like they are supposed
to be like best of the best in MJ's God
I mean the element of surprise is very
is a formidable attack to be fair I mean
I get what you're saying but they don't
know I think front and back covered
maybe I can go through the basement
doesn't not have the years and years and
years of training
part of them being a hunter is to be
prepared for elements of
surprise thank
you saying MJ would be
dead head squashed and everything P's
workbench The Last of Us I always
mention that we got Abby from Last of Us
Part Two but you know the voice of Miles
Morales right not you yeah Sam from Last
of Us oh nice
freeze
yeah oh my God
MJ
yeah hey she's hot very hot very hot
stuff she is not a damn Zone distress I
know she wasn't at all in the first game
either but now she's extra a bad ass I
really think they took some aesthetic
inspiration from last of us a little bit
in this one
you the hunters and stuff oh yeah yeah
yeah totally with the seraphites a
little bit yeah I could to I was
thinking that
actually those are the teeth Peter that
is not my
boyfriend what about the face P does
that remind you of prey a little bit
Peter I need need you to
come
yikes oh the
terror is she going to start singing the
song Lose Yourself by
Eminem miles look
up oh no they fighting stop wait are
they the tunnel
yeah I
H cuz everything's in the
shadows
stupid she said go after him but I
thought that was just more a protective
thing not fight
him I mean trying to stop
him oh
[Music]
noises
well at least she knows now what weakens
him his straight up sci-fi
whor oh I don't think he was figh mil he
was just fighting
himself just like know you're still in
there the amount of detail of the flesh
is gross yeah you have to be
[Music]
oh it's really formulating to his potty
yeah
Spiderman oh no the crane won't
respond a oh
[Music]
damn not of Spider-Man World
construction workers are't in danger
right it's like a Spider-Man
staple hang
[Music]
on love how is the lottery building oh
my God what an unexpected turn of evance
wow
possible that was good
you welcome
ah
no all right they got me
too that's a dirty
trick that was
dirty open
it Pete wake
up get up Spider-Man wake up
don't worry MJ I believe you can kick
all their asses oh
easily you've been knocking out these
Hunters left and right a little uhoh
this will wake him
[Music]
up that's how Greg wakes me up every
time I'm nodding off on this
channel just flick your balls whichever
run ah you can hear the
voice oh my God oh my God this is
straight up a horor so scary oh
man look don't look don't
look all right now I want Craven to
catch up I know right that's dichotomy
of your
feelings MJ can take out hunters and she
can outr run
Venom man the music
here pulsating pulsating ass
music I just love how it's it's kind of
like the fly or something right you know
just like slowly morphing into a better
than I did
Miles that's a good comparison we
searched the whole
tunnel he is gone cuz there's straight
up body
horor this is also a great example to
Sony of how you can make venom
terrifying without resorting to an RoR
rating
he's not even Venom yet you
know true and he's absolutely
terrifying almost sounded like Tony Todd
right
there no I think yeah we're getting Shad
at Tony Tod
[Music]
rout you think dream
sequence has to be everyone's wearing
the same outfit I was going to say New
York's also not destroyed why are so
many people wearing the same
outfit
yeah it's got to
be
okay oh you think like the symbios just
put him in his own
mind yeah no no no damn that's played
that way though huh
huh
oh now he's recklessly with property
damage but before there
wasn't dude he is
dying where's Norman and all this you
need to focus on getting that back to
him how you
feeling I wonder if he thinks Peter's
like intentionally hogging it I need
that suit
back oo the defensiveness in his
[Music]
eyes wait is is this really this is
really happening judgment be clouded man
what do you remember about last night
okay I just remember feeling
[Music]
tired you're becoming disillusion man
that suit is changing in you this suit
is the only reason I'm still
alive yeah it's pretty great isn't it
why don't you pop some more pills and
say what you're really
feel my out there trying to save you and
this is what I get I said
don't I saw your
story I tried to tell you about that
yeah but you didn't did
you I can't lose this job your job is to
write the truth she is she is this is
such great storytelling it's so dramatic
the hero here not you oh man that's mean
that's so mean I say it to John every
day love how she had that behind her
back just in
case that's weird how it wasn't
corrupting Harry though huh that's
that's what I was trying to say earlier
but it is it still is like
a oh nor not exactly an addiction
metaphor but it is facial ha
Norman I know I want to think it's a
stressed out Shadow but it still looks
well put together you know
oh how was your visit with
Harry I'm the Green
[Music]
Goblin don't worry Harry's going to get
better yeah when you give him that suit
you selfish bastard
hey he's the hero
thank
you for being his
friend man he really loves him I love
that this is how they chose to tell the
story yeah they're humanizing him so
much I'm not used to it Norman well he
was so in love with his wife too so yeah
grow up
together you're like a son to me oh is
getting
jealous there it is man yeah okay I'm
now I'm buying that
Venom dude the man you've become I'm
really buying it
now it was just the statue in the build
that's that was Mr
Osborne I I got to
run that made me very uncomfortable Mr
Osborne it's kind of uh vulnerability
and intimacy is not something I'm in the
mood for right now
it's going to be interesting though how
it didn't corrupt Harry oh what's he
looking at though he green green goblets
it's interesting that it didn't corrupt
Harry at first and then it's going to
later just maybe it takes more time I
don't know he needs his
drug are you
okay
go please damn he's being stripped of
everything everything
yeah kiss him while making food in the
kitchen I said leave I understood that
reference it was Amazing Spider-Man 2
right
mhm kidding people I know Spider-Man 3 I
don't need you to say in the comments
the shatter glass is a metaphor for his
state of mind a lot of work to do
and as usual looks like I got to do it
myself oh God there's a little bit of
symbiote in all of us Peter where is
Miles he didn't come home last night and
he's not answering I don't know
back off I'm at my office tell him to
come see me now you pay my ass take care
of themselves it's always up to me oh
God so can tankers I love it no I'm sure
he's fine but give me a call if you see
him D that's a great pict picture thanks
too
miles I've been calling you for hours
nothing you know miles has been hunting
Lee I'll find
him that's comforting calling the
hospital I said I'd find him ooh I've
got this under
control no no all miles talks about is
how to be a better Spider-Man that
school not his
friends how to help you need to be a
better mentor Peter go help him
damn you're not my mom Rio back
off how did I get
here
problem Oh new problem
arest come on you know how to get
through lasers uncle Aaron Tau you like
an Austin Powers trap this place has
tight
security that looks like an
exit is this the same Mansion you think
just have to get out of here and call
Spider-Man he's
okay
okay what's going
on this feels very
tribal uh it's going to be a one-on-one
fight him and the
tiger it's all right man if MJ can kick
half their asses you can kick whoever
ass this is and you've got bio
electricity and camouflage
it's like a gladiator fight yeah
right are you not
[Applause]
entertained
There's No Escape oh no did not see
that coming not at all damn that's
amazing I expected you sooner what a
personal fight where is the energy of
Youth
huh did Craven know why would he pick
that up death wow die here together oh
Dam so how many people did you kill kill
before I got
here I didn't have a choice you always
have a choice does Martin Lee feel
regretful for his past decisions does
you see the error of his ways I don't
know welcome back Venom
po what choice to fight to the
death
w do this my way I feel like you two
could work together and break out of
here oh no it's affected by the negative
energy
Yik no way Straight From Hell this it's
you this is some love crafty and I
need to keep my head in the game I'm not
really here right now none of this is
real what's more real it's real in your
mind
though you're
right that's more than enough I have
everything I
need just this deep dive plunge into
Terror
man time marish existential
dread oh no I had a feeling we were
going here it's is going to get me more
pissed hey there big
man man it feels good to see you that's
changed since I left you became a whole
hero just to go just could save you more
fin if Spider-Man can't protect
everyone who will come on now you're
more than just Spider-Man you can try
and hide behind that MK but I know who
you are this seems empowering what you
stand for it seems positive I've been
watching you you have and it hurts
you've been a
failure you've been a disappointed
miles yes literally fighting as
demons who you're done
me I'm not doing this
anymore you want to know who I am I'm
the kid whose dad you killed at City
Hall this feels like spiderverse you
died because you decided your problems
were more important than all of those
people's lives Jefferson Davis was a
hero who saved people from
you yeah it is interesting Martin Lee
was there to kill the man who killed he
felt was responsible for his parents
death and then created the same thing
miles
no
I'm done listening to you losing my
dad this does feel like spiderverse
inspiration I was the one doing
that but not
[Music]
anymore
wa damn that was a great transition rain
in hell I love how Craven kept him in
his raft outf
do
it do it
now finish
him when you're out fine Spider-Man
what do not let them
Escape he's just going to trust him like
that
damn I guess Martin Le getting the
Redemption Arc I hope so he was an all
right guy before all this I mean he was
actually I really did like him a lot I
left the best parts of me
here
a and we never got to see his reaction
to
me oh I'm not looking for a fight Craven
as the other Spider-Man trapped in an
old mansion east of the
city he saved me
told me to find
you this was the only way I knew
how I owe him my
life and much
more if we hurry no you've done
enough hey he's trying to be Mr positive
right now proud of
him you trained him well he reminds me
of you Peter you know before you were an
say Peter
wow you'd hope the new Spider-Man
reminds me of the old Spider-Man you
know
that's I wonder if the little spider
Will
Survive you could just feel the anger
seething in him feel like there's a lot
of time spent with these henchmen yikes
oh my
god oh no no do
[Applause]
it do you like Yuri lowenthal's
interrogation skills better or Christian
bal's just
car I just love like the at
the evil and the confidence that comes
with
it uh-oh I'm assured that material is
unbreakable how about for symbi but I
believe
anything can be broken that's a great
line
we haven't even gotten a Venom yet
this is so
great you still hold
back so he's been trying to break him
down entirely so he can become as that's
what I love about him he's not just a a
physical threat he's a psychologically
and mental
threat
yeah
oh my God now you're in for
it
whoa that's
terrifying come on hit
me my
God what chance do you think you have
Craven like dud that's what he wants he
he wants him to wants the fight ofra
possibly have a chance though
how
beautiful but you still hold back kill
wants to or be kill he really wants the
murderer him to come
out oh
I love how getting the difference of
ideologies oh God the anatomy of all
this is so twisted and
FY
ah stop did he say
harder
yeah trying to provoke him it's just
getting
killed is some of it still on
him I think some of it still on cre
uhuh I
just oh dude he's so
scary it's just
me
ah holy it's like creating a
forest
waa oh
bams whoa I need this suit makes me a
better
Spider-Man no you just want it for
yourself it makes you a worse Spider-Man
because it'll clouds your
choices all I want is to save you I'm
the hero I don't get SI if you're
nothing without the suit then you
shouldn't have it at all wa what a great
shot
there oh look at that Peter is the
villain yeah
whoa I love the darkness to which they
pushed him here I'm finally everything
everyone needs me to be yeah you don't
even answer my calls anymore man yeah
yeah it's all
that they've been breaking apart for a
while now ever since
he Romancing with Harry
again and what about MJ you could have
killed
her
I know you're hurting PE it's crazy how
miles is overpowering better than this I
know I know
but no this makes me feel
good love all the
shapes that that suit come does my life
they keep dying I blamed myself for that
they needed a hero and if I thought some
Su could SA them maybe I'd be in your
shoes
now but this kind of power is the reason
they're gone not you not me shut
up I just love the manifestation of all
this
chaos it's just like a
plague of
Darkness let's give that suit a t is the
Venom yeah
yeah oh right cuz the
sound good think this giant Bell is
here yeah love the Venom jump
sick
whoa o oh
[Music]
boy
oh that is so great that they let you
actually fight Peter Parker as the
villain that's
amazing we got to be stronger than that
this is where mediums hold back to save
yourself
you
will I'm not losing you
pe how miles will inspire him that's
[Music]
beautiful I'm GL I'm glad the uh come on
get your timing down GL the editor of
this kept this part of the game play in
yeah it's very necessary part of the
story this is like a fight the story
with a a fight with a real story
to just like it's emotional Story Time
like Peter's fighting internally but
then the Symbiote is fighting externally
so much like there's it's so much
desperation miles
desperate and honestly if I had a
controler in my hand I wouldn't be
making any of these observations
properly or cohesively hey come on man
just just focus on
me
come on I'm stronger than this you hear
me fight the battle
within rip it
off yes
yes oh it's underneath that's so damn
you just had that suit on the whole time
time
wow this is
terrible going back to
Harry how dare you reject
me
oh need to shoot that thing into space
right now I don't know how but you need
to
that fight was extremely emotional yeah
it was
beautiful you have a lot of apologizing
to
do these last few
days miles I'm
sorry thank you for
everything it's what Spider-Man do
break it
[Music]
open Spider-Man didn't save me back
there miles miles did some sometimes
that's what Haley meant sometimes you
don't need SP wrestl you need miles well
was the same thing with against Otto
Spider-Man didn't beat him Peter did
shut up Andrew I'm making a point not
you I'm the point man right now wait
what about got to get that symbi of you
isn't he kind of need
it his dad is working on another C
one that doesn't involve aliens he's
going to feel betrayed me I just a call
away well once I let my mom know this
she still has a
son I know oh my God I think I know
what's going to
[Music]
happen